bitcoin has the single most predictable
monetary policy in the world that may
sound like a bombastic claim but if you
actually go into the data and you look
it's true what do i mean recently jack
mullers was interviewed and he was
talking exactly about this bitcoin's
monetary policy is programmatic there
aren't any humans that are actually
involved in making changes on a
short-term or long-term basis bitcoin's
monetary policy is code and it's simply
execute exactly as it was designed
anyone in the world is able to go in and
audit that code and see if it is
executing correctly here's some of
jack's comments in the recent interview
so he specifically did point out your
gold analogy and he said that it would
be ridiculous to go to a physical store
and pay with uh you know physical gold
bars what is your response that given
the fact that you mentioned that you
view bitcoin as a form of digital gold
yeah so let's look at the history of
money for a second the reason gold was
valuable is its abil ability to travel
through time it's money's ability to
travel through time i could put a gold
bar under my mattress and it didn't
matter the rate of inflation that the
united states was under who was at war
whether real estate in miami was bearish
or bullish
gold carried a sufficient amount of
value due to stock to flow ratio due to
its scarcity due to its relative
hardness that's the important part and
then fiat currency fiat notes were
traditionally introduced to enhance its
ability to travel through space
to make sure that that gold was in
exchange for candy at a candy store and
we had gold back notes and together it
created a monetary environment where you
could transmit value across space and
time yeah now bitcoin in its initial
form
is optimized around the time i can for
the first time digitally move a million
dollars from here to the year 2140 that
is a remarkable accomplishment and it
uses proof-of-work 10-minute block times
distributed consensus a distributed
network a fixed supply a known issuance
policy to achieve that and then things
like the lightning network can be
layered on top of it to enhance its
ability to travel through space
and so this is known it's been
relatively known throughout the industry
for the last decade and so comments like
spending bitcoin is akin to spending a
gold bar make no sense bitcoin
encompasses and embodies the ability to
travel money through both space and time
and the most miraculous inclusive open
accessible innovative way we've ever
seen in human history and so dissuading
people from using this innovation is
extremely disingenuous and extremely
against what humans are about in moving
our species forward i'm so violently
against that behavior and i really hope
sam just has no idea what he's talking
about as opposed to what i think would
be a malicious act
now one of the key things that jack's
pointing out here is that a central bank
it has to be independent but it also has
to be reliable you have to understand
what they're going to do in the future
human-led central banks they end up
actually having lots of volatility is
the federal reserve going to raise
interest rates 25 50 75 basis points
will they surprise us with 100 basis
points at what point will they pause
interest rate hikes are they going to
continue with quantitative tightening
will they return to quantitative easing
nobody actually knows but when you have
a programmatic monetary policy like
bitcoin it is the single most reliable
monetary policy that is available to
anyone in the world but not only is it
the single most reliable monetary policy
in the world it's also the most
consistent and that's a really important
point bitcoin is the only monetary
policy in the world that's done exactly
what it said it was going to do for the
last 13 years every other central bank
in the world said they were going to do
one thing and eventually changed their
mind they pivoted or they digressed from
their strategy bitcoin is the signal in
all of the noise and bitcoin continues
to do exactly as it was designed i think
that more and more people over time will
find value in a programmatic monetary
policy and bitcoin will be the big
winner there